hey guys justin here with a gamespot
news update during a pax east panel
today the CEO of harmonics teased that
they have grand plans to bring their
biggest franchise to a next-gen console
the CEO of harmonics prefaced his talk
by saying he is not announcing a rock
band 4 or dance central for at this time
but they did not say if these games were
in development or not he did say the
rock band and dance central franchises
are near and dear to our hearts and
minds and we have grand plans to bring
back both of them with guns blazing at
some point in the coming console cycle
he has said previously that the rock
band franchise will return at the right
time the most recent game in the core
series was rock band 3 back in 2010
looking at comments for the story many
of our readers think that the competing
franchise from Ubisoft rocksmith has
changed the game too much and returning
to the plastic instruments of Guitar
Hero and Rock Band is a step backwards
others warn harmonics that they
shouldn't release a rock band that
doesn't honor previous DLC purchases
let's hear your thoughts on the story in
the comments below and for even more
news about pax east be sure to stay
tuned to gamespot com